l'accord était attendue depuis plusieurs
semaines part volodymyr zelensky les
européens se passeront de 90% du pétrole
qui les achète à la russie d'ici la fin
de l'année en plus de l'embargo trois
banques russes vont être coupés du
réseau de paiement international swift
et trois chaînes de télévision accusé de
désinformation ne pourront plus diffusés
dans l'union européenne
un sixième paquet de sanctions contre
moscou qui aura des conséquences sur le
pouvoir d'achat on peut avoir
effectivement 2 euros 22 euros 30 à la
pompe ça serait pas
oui ça serait mieux possible en ne pas
être capable d'organiser une grande
rencontre internationale
à la veille des jeux olympiques à la
coupe du monde de rugby c'est une
humiliation
esti personnes qui vont être jugés en
comparution immédiate risque jusqu'à
cinq ans de prison deux d'entre elles
sont jugées pour vol avec violence un
homme de 25 ans qui aurait volé la
montre d'une victime mexicaine venus
assister au match et même de 34 ans qui
a volé le collier d'une victime
britannique dans la journée monsieur
darmanin faits tweete en dix ans la
plupart des interpellations soit des
britanniques et hier soir au journal de
tf1 il deale inverse il y a quasiment
plus de britanniques donc on voit bien
que la version est totalement
incohérente on organise l'événement
incendies depuis vingt ans il n'y a
jamais eu autant de phénomènes de
délinquance que s'il y en a eu dard
hachage extérieur cost y en a eu samedi
dernier plutôt que de dire en
seine-saint-denis il ya un problème avec
la seine-saint-denis on est dans une
zone de non droit on a un problème avec
ces quartiers si on avait fait la finale
ailleurs que dans le stade de france
ferait aucun problème si on avait été à
charléty gto il y aurait eu aucun
problème à l'extérieur avec ce type de
banque on ne peut pas nier la réalité
c'est qu'il y à une violence dans cette
partie de l'île de france et que des
voyous ont débarqué et on fait on fait
les pires choses les agressions sénat
mais la situation n 1 mais twitter vous
confirmez vous avez vraiment des
agressions multiples et c'est absolument
insupportable
voilà il faut le dire et on peut pas
accueillir le monde dans ces conditions
la fente privé quel bâtiment en face du
stade de france ils ont des notes
internes aux salariés dans lesquels on
leur dit les femmes ne doivent pas
sortir seul le soir le lien couvre-feu
passer certainement plus personne au
bureau il faut rentrer avant telle heure
etc des consignes ont été données par le
président de la république sur la base
d'une analyse complètement faux ce qui
est de 2 pas énerver les électeurs de
mélenchon est donc surtout ne rien dire
de mal de ce qui se passe dans les
quartiers qui ne sont pas traitées nous
avons de grands industriels y compris
français comme thales qui aujourd'hui
ont des systèmes très au point pour
garantir les libertés individuelles et
que seules les personnes fichées puisse
être détecté par intelligence
artificielle un plan vert de 632 mètres
de long suspendu à 150 mètres du sol si
vertigineux que spectaculaire il a été
inauguré dans le nord ouest du vietnam
et c'est officiellement le plus long de
la catégorie votre taux de présence en
séance dépasse à peine les 20 % et ne
cesse de décroître oui un constat
unanime paris vous ennuie c'est donc le
chiffre que l'on redoute l inflation
continue sur sa lancée les prix ont
encore grimpé de 5,2 pour cent sur un an
au mois de mai et selon l'insee
désormais tout augmente cette présence
est aussi anecdotique que votre score à
l'élection présidentielle d'un virgule 7
% oui ça fait mal
1,7 pour cent sont loin d'être des
professionnels de la politique et
pourtant ils tentent leur chance c'est
le cas de l'humoriste laurent baffie il
est candidat à paris pour le parti
animalistes et regardez il met son
humour au service de son affiche de
campagne avec un caneton je serai avec
les collègues de la majorité
garante du fait que cette assemblée ne
sera pas dévoyé dans ce cirque pitoyable
patrick balkany c'est plus compliqué
reste en prison absolument à 73 ans
l'ancien maire de levallois perret avait
obtenu sa libération conditionnelle son
bracelet électronique mais le parquet
d'evry a décidé de faire appel